the fired minneapolis police officer
convicted of murdering george floyd will
be sentenced this afternoon
floyd died on memorial day last year
after derrick chauvin kneeled on his
neck for more than nine minutes during
an arrest
his death led to one of the largest
protest movements in u.s
history demanding police reform and
racial justice
the prosecution wants chauvin to be
sentenced to 30 years in prison
the defense team is asking for probation
with no further prison time
joining us now is sherida tate and
george floyd who was george floyd's
cousin and
attorney ben crump with the floyd family
first of all good morning to both of you
thank you for
uh being with us first question to you
sharita i know that your family has said
that
faith and hope has gotten you all
through this
after the conviction what are you hoping
to hear from the judge today
i'm hoping to hear that he will get the
maximum sentence allowed under the law
and that would be 30 years
and ben you know that the prosecution as
we just mentioned
is asking for 30 years do you think that
is likely and is that enough in your
opinion what would be
the appropriate amount of time
we have always asked that
the appropriate sentence would be what
they would have sentenced george floyd
to
had the rose been reversed
we only see equal justice in this matter
we believe
that george would have been convicted of
first degree murder
and he would be facing life in prison
however
we believe if the judge sentences derek
children's for 30 years
that would be significant progress for
the quest of equal justice in america
sharita do you plan to give a message to
the judge today and what do you want
the judge to take away from what you and
other family members have to say
well i think what i would want the judge
to take away is what we've been
saying all along is that we we expect to
see justice in
in this uh case uh our cousin was
murdered and
though the sentence that's being offered
is not enough time and i don't think
there is
any amount of time that would be
justifiable in our minds
i think you know the messaging should be
all the evidence points to the fact and
he's been convicted and now we just need
the 30-year sentence
in terms of hearing from derek shobin
which is unclear if he's going to speak
does it matter do you care to hear what
he has to say
today if he speaks at all
no i don't care to hear from her
at all i don't think there's anything
that he could say that would change my
perception of what happened on may 25th
2020.
um so i mean any in in my opinion and i
think i can speak for
my family and in its entirety none of us
really care to hear anything he has to
say
ben uh it's anthony minnesota's attorney
general keith ellison took the unusual
step of asking the public
to send in victim impact statements i'm
curious what you make of that
i think anthony it was a profound thing
to do
this was unlike anything we had ever
seen in america i mean
it galvanized people all across america
all across the globe
when they watch that torture video for
nine minutes
and 29 seconds and so i think
america had ptsd and so
i think where attorney general ellison
wanted to do
is let the judge know that the whole
world is watching
the whole world is watching today
sharita it's tony to copel it's been two
months since
we heard that guilty verdict in the case
what are those two months been like for
your family and where does the family go
from here
well i think uh you know for all of us
it was sort of a sigh of relief
for lack of a better way of expressing
it i think we just exhale
you know as we heard one conviction
after the other
and so going from here is just
continuing to work to make sure that
there are
you know some changes that will affect
generations to come
as it relates to social justice our
family has committed to doing that since
day one and
we have not stopped and we will continue
to be present and actively working
towards that
and the united states senate needs to
pass the george floyd justin and
policing act
immediately so we can stop some of these
hashtags
from happening and black people being
killed unjustly
sherida tate and ben crump thank you so
much for joining us this morning stay
with cbs news
for continuing coverage of chauvin's
sentencing we will bring you a special
report
when he is sentenced this afternoon